El Congreso de Perú en las últimas horas
levantó la inmunidad al expresidente
Pedro Castillo eso le permite a la
fiscalía contar con mejores herramientas
para procesarlo el Ministerio Público Ha
logrado establecer que el expresidente
Castillo sí habría cometido los delitos
de rebelión y conspiración Porque habría
recibido la participación la ayuda de la
ex primer ministra Betsy Chávez y
también de algunos colaboradores
los fiscales están contando también con
la participación de un testigo quien les
afirma que el expresidente Castillo
ordenó al comandante general de la
policía peruana cerrar el congreso
impedir el paso de los legisladores al
palacio legislativo y también capturar
con prioridad a la fiscal general de
Perú Patricia Benavides es con todo este
sustento de pruebas y otros detalles que
han obtenido documentación de el Palacio
de Gobierno es que se forma esta
denuncia penal de la fiscalía Francisco
si la presidenta Dina boluarte anunció
el adelanto de elecciones a abril de
2024 qué es lo que se exigen en las
manifestaciones Por qué continúan las
protestas en Perú
el ministro de defensa Alberto tarola
afirma que son algunas autoridades del
interior del Perú que están
desestabilizando las regiones es por eso
que se ha dispuesto el cese de los
prefectos del interior del país y es que
en realidad a ellos no les interesa el
adelanto de elecciones Ellos dicen que
no van a parar hasta que renuncie la
presidenta Dina boluarte y también
exigen que se cierre el parlamento la
jornada de violencia en este país ha
llevado a los manifestantes a bloquear
tramos de la carretera Panamericana que
une El Perú justamente en algunos tramos
de la carretera para americana Norte y
la Panamericana Sur existe bloqueos y
quema de llantas Mientras tanto en la
región de Arequipa lo manifestantes han
podido controlar el aeropuerto de esa
localidad y queman llantas en la pista
de aterrizaje y aquí Lima las
autoridades de esta capital peruana
están tratando de redoblar el control y
las medidas de seguridad del Aeropuerto
Internacional Jorge Chávez porque tiene
la información de inteligencia que se
está organizando una toma violenta de
este Aeropuerto Internacional en Lima